Well,
I'd like to start,
uh,
with a little more discussion of Derrida before we turn to demand.
Uh,
and I know already that I'm going to forego what for me is a kind of pleasure,
uh,
perhaps wouldn't be for you a which is an explication,
which,
which is an explication of the last extraordinary sentence in Derrida's essay on
page nine 26 and the right hand column.
I'm going to read it to you.
Um,
just so you can reflect on it.
And what I'd like to do is suggest to you that if you still haven't determined
on a paper topic,
you might very well consider this one.
I you may not find it congenial.
That's a buzzing,
that you are intrigued by Derrida,
uh,
to account for this last sentence,
to show how it picks up motifs generated throughout the essay,
how it returns the essay to its beginning,
uh,
and to consider very carefully it's metaphors.
It reflects on its old metaphors.
I think you might find intriguing passages here.
There is a sort of question,
call it historical of which we are only glimpsing today.
The conception,
the formation,
the gestation,
the Labor.
I employ these words,
I admit with a glance toward the business of child bearing,
but also with a glance store.
Those who in a company from which I do not exclude myself turned their eyes away
in the face of the as yet unnameable which is proclaiming itself and which can
do so as is necessary whenever a birth is in the offing only under the species
of the non species in the formless mute infant and terrifying form of
monstrosity.
All right,
well there is a sentence for you,
uh,
and as I say,
I don't have time to explicate it,
but I commend it to you as a possible paper topic if you're still in need of one
right now.
I do want to go back to the relationship between Derrida and Levy Strauss.
I suggested last time that while in some ways the essay really seems to stage
itself as a critique of Levy Strauss at the same time to a remarkable degree
confessor unconfessed,
it stands on the shoulders of Levy Strauss.
At the same time.
However,
having made use of Levy Strauss,
finding a means of distancing himself from the source text.
Take for example,
paid nine 24 over onto nine 25 when he can,
when he quotes from Levis Strauss,
uh,
the as a Levy Strauss is introduction to the work of Boxville a mouse,
on the subject of the birth or event or emergence of language and what it grotes
from Levis Strauss would seem on the face of it to have exactly the same kinds
of reservation hesitation about the emergence or birth of language that Derrida
himself has.
Levy Strauss writes whatever may have been the moment and the circumstances of
its appearance in the scale of animal life language could only have been born in
one fell swoop.
Things could not have said about signifying progressively following a
transformation.
The study of which is not the concern of the social sciences,
but rather of biology and psychology.
Uh,
crossing over came about from a stage where nothing had a meaning to another
where everything possessed it.
In other words,
Bam.
All of a sudden you had language,
you had a semiotic system,
whereas before yesterday,
a minute ago,
you had no language at all.
In other words,
there's no notion that somehow or another,
suddenly I looked at something and said,
oh,
that has a meaning.
And then you know,
somehow or another I looked at something else and said,
oh,
that has a meaning.
And in the long run,
Lo and behold,
I had language because the bringing into existence of the very thought of
meaning Levy Strauss wants to argue instantly confers meaning on everything.
In other words,
you don't have,
you don't have a gradual emergence of language.
You have like lava emerging from a volcano,
oh rupture.
You have something which suddenly appears amid other things,
something which is latent in those things,
although they don't in themselves have it until you confirm it on them.
Mainly that which confers meaning language.
All right,
so this is Levy.
Strauss is argument and Derrida is interested in it because he recognizes it's
affinity with his own hesitation in talking about events and births and
emergence and so on.
But at the same time,
at the same time,
he points out by way of criticism that disappears that yesterday there was no
language,
there was just things as they are without meaning and that today there is
language that things have meaning as a result of their now being in place.
That semiotic system we call language.
He points out that this means that culture somehow or another must come after
nature.
There was nature.
Now there is culture which is very much like an event or birth in the older
sense.
In fact,
as soon as we have culture and Levy Strauss expresses this,
this feeling especially in a famous book called [inaudible].
As soon as we have culture,
we began to feel overwhelming nostalgia for nature but says Derrida,
what is this nostalgia other than the fact that the very thing we're nostalgic
for comes into existence as a result of the nostalgic and other words,
there is no nature unless you have culture to think it.
Nature is a meaningless concept.
Just like the lack of meaning within nature where there is no culture until
culture comes along and says,
oh,
not,
not so much.
There is nature,
but I'm terribly unhappy because before I came along there was nature.
Right?
And this is the nostalgia or regret of the ethnographer who says now as a result
of this terrible Eurocentrism as a result of the terrible ethnocentrism of the
European studying these things,
we no longer have a savage mind.
That is to say we no longer have the kind of mind which flourishes in nature in
a natural environment.
You can see ramifications of arguments of this sort for environmentalism as well
as for ethnography.
Uh,
it's a fascinating argument,
but the bottom line is this,
even this critique,
and it is a critique of Levis Strauss because you know,
he's saying,
oh,
Levy Strauss.
That's very interesting what you say about language,
but you've forgotten that this means that you yourself must think nature
preceded culture even though culture brings nature into being.
Okay.
But this very critique leveled against Levy Strauss he could have found in Levis
Strauss and does find it on other occasions.
Levy Strauss,
his famous book,
the raw and the cooked essentially stages.
This critique in and of itself.
What do you mean raw?
Well,
you know,
somebody is eating gonna feel is sitting in a field eating a carrot that's raw.
You say,
but wait a minute.
You know what is this notion of raw?
You can't have a notion of Ra until you have the notion of cooked.
You know,
I sit in my field,
I'm eating my carrot,
I hold it up and I say,
this is raw.
It's ridiculous.
What raw as opposed to what?
Right.
And so there can be no raw without in a certain sense,
the prior existence of cooked,
cooked brings raw into being in exactly the way culture brings nature into
being.
Now to pause over this for a moment,
I mean,
eh,
and we realized that this basic move,
a move that when you start to think about it,
we've been encountering ever since we started reading in this course of readings
is not so much the inversion of binary's as the calling into question of how
they can exist apart from each other.
In other words,
this the,
the,
the question of,
of criticizing the origin of one state of things out of or after another state
of things.
The process of criticizing that is basically,
and I'm sorry to be so reductive about it,
but I really can't see the distortion and saying this is basically saying which
came first,
the chicken or the egg,
right?
It is,
it is a,
it is a declaration of Absolute Indi interdependency among the things that we
take that we understand in binary terms,
but we take somehow one to be causative of the other when we think about them.
This is really the basic move of deconstruction,
but it's a move which anyone who studies philosophy as well as literary theory
will encounter again and again and again,
all the way from Hegel,
right on through the thinkers post deconstructive thinkers we encounter for the
rest of our syllabus.
Uh,
uh,
perhaps preeminently among them,
the gender theorists,
Judith Butler again and again and again,
you will encounter this idea in butler.
It's a question of saying how on earth would you ever have the concept
heterosexual if you didn't have the concept homosexual in place?
Right?
They are.
The absolute interdependency of this concept of these concepts is again,
uh,
central to her argument and to her understanding of things.
And so,
and obviously we'll be returning to that in the long run.
I want to pause a little bit more than in this regard.
Over dairy does distinction between writing and speech writing a criteria.
Uh,
this is a distinction which is not meant sort of counterintuitively to suggest
that somehow or another
as opposed to what we usually think writing precedes speech.
Not at all.
He's not saying,
he's not saying that we've got it backwards.
He's just insisting that we cannot understand writing to be derivative.
We cannot say writing came in to being belatedly with respect to speech in order
to reproduce or to imitate or to transcribe.
Speech writing and speech are interdependent and interrelated phenomena which do
different things.
Last time we spoke about DFL Os we said that the difference between diff our
house with an e and different routes with an ae can't be voiced.
It's a difference or defect loss that comes into being precisely in writing and
it's only in writing that we suddenly grasp the twofold nature of different Os
as difference and deferral.
I'd like to pause a little bit,
and this will be my segue to demand,
right?
To pause a little bit over.
An interesting example in French,
which we don't have in English but is I think so instructive that it's worth
pausing over.
Okay.
You remember last time and there is a slight voicing difference here,
just as there's also a slight different voicing difference defect.
Hans,
do you feel at all so,
but it's not a big voicing difference.
It's not.
It's,
it's,
it's not something that's easier,
easy to evoke and get across.
Whereas in writing it's perfectly obvious.
For one thing,
the ass,
which means signification is dropped out of this word.
When you say w w when you say,
Hey,
the word for is the word for aunt.
Now these two words precisely expressed in French,
but Derrida is trying to describe as the double meaning of supplement charity is
and the sense of the matter for this is that a is B understood as a metaphor is
a supplement that creek that that completes a whole,
it's a means of completing a hole through the declaration that a is B but is has
another sense in which,
which is not a rhetorical sense that because metaphor is is you know the sort of
the heart of,
of,
of rhetoric.
The rhetorical sense a is B when by the way we know perfectly well today is not
be,
I mean how can ABB Aa is only a,
in fact it's even a question whether hey is a but it's certainly not be right so
this,
this much we know but in the,
in in the grammatical sense there is no sort of mystification about the metaphor
in the grammatical sense.
This word is the print is the means or principle of predication.
Whereby we say one thing is another thing.
The mayor is the female of the horse.
Notice that the relationship between the rhetorical is and their grammatical is,
is basically the relationship between y'all,
what y'all Gibson calls the poetic function and the metal lingual function.
Okay.
So add,
as you'll see in demand,
there is a an eight and had irreducible tension between the rhetorical sense of
this word which claims metaphor [inaudible] and their grammatical sense of this
word which makes no such claim but as simply the establishment of uh,
of the,
of,
of the PR of predication in a sentence.
Now the word eh,
which is,
which is a,
are a,
which is almost like that reinforces the idea of the supplement not as the
completion of something that that is,
that as the completion of something needs it to be complete,
the fulfillment of meaning and a matter of her,
but rather supplement and the sense of adding on to something that's already
complete and the APP positional sort of grammatical,
perpetual edition of meaning in the expression and or a is after all very much
like what y'all person calls met anemic.
That is to say the con,
the contiguous adding on of things,
making no claim to be metaphorical,
just like grammatical predication.
And so the tension or the,
the,
the system of differences that can be established simply by looking at these two
voice,
similar words I think gives us a kind of emblem or paradigm for what dairy doc
calls supplement it supplementaries city and what demand calls the irreducible
tension between difference between conflict,
between rhetoric and grammar,
and that it will be then that is the main topic of what we have to say about
demand today.
Now,
last time I said a little bit about the presence of dairy and demand together
together with scholar named Jay Hillis,
Miller,
uh,
scholars who associated themselves with them.
Jeffrey Hartman,
Harold bloom in a kind of period of flourishing in the 70s and early eighties at
Yale,
uh,
called abroad,
the Yale School,
a subject,
too much admiration in the academy and much vilification both within and outside
the academy.
Uh,
but a moment of particular,
uh,
and headlined notoriety,
in the history of academic thinking about literature,
a moment in which academic thinking about literature had a peculiar influence on
topics,
much broader than literature began to infiltrate other disciplines,
uh,
and was,
in general,
um,
a high spirit and horse for that certain period of time.
Now,
shortly after the witness and then Miller,
eventually in the 80s,
went to Irvine Derrida.
I followed him there.
And in,
uh,
1983 bald Amman died.
And the,
uh,
well the,
the main,
the main force,
uh,
of the movement began to give way to other interests and other,
and other tendencies and trends both here at Yale and elsewhere.
Um,
and then,
uh,
shortly after demands death,
there was a revelation which is mentioned by your editor in the italicized
preface to semiology and rhetoric,
there was a revelation about demand,
which was horrible in itself,
uh,
made it impossible ever to read demonn in quite the same way again,
but,
which was also,
I have to say precisely what the enemies of deconstruction we're waiting for.
Uh,
and that was the fact that,
um,
in his youth,
uh,
demand still living in Belgium,
the sun,
uh,
the,
the nephew of a distinguished socialist politician in Belgium,
uh,
wrote for a Nazi sponsored Belgian newspaper,
a series of articles,
uh,
antisemitic intendancy,
a couple of them openly,
uh,
antisemitic,
or at least sort of racially Eurocentric and ways that,
you know,
argued for the exclusion of Jews from the intellectual life of Europe.
And so on.
Uh,
these papers were a pub were gathered and published as Paul demands wartime
journalism.
Uh,
and there was a tremendous,
fewer about them,
similar to the revelations about height,
which I'd never been completely repressed,
but the B seemed to w grew in magnitude as more and more was known about them,
the revolutions about a,
uh,
Heidegger's association with the Nazi government.
Uh,
and,
and during,
and in the late eighties,
um,
there was,
uh,
a few,
a furious public argumentation back and forth,
uh,
between those both,
um,
who had read demand and those who hadn't,
uh,
who,
were opposed to his work and those who,
uh,
scrambled,
in one way or another to attempt to defend it,
to preserve his legacy and also the legacy of deconstruction.
Uh,
now all of this is a matter of record and I suppose needs to be paused,
paused over a little bit.
One of the,
uh,
one of the texts of demand also in the book called allegories of Reading,
where you'll find also a version of the essay semiology and rhetoric that you
read for today.
One of the essays that those would actually read demand,
actually argued about in a persistent fashion is called the purloined ribbon.
And it has to do with the passage in Rousseau's confessions where Russo has
stolen a ribbon,
uh,
in order to give it to a serving made to whom he was t he felt attraction.
Uh,
and then when he was asked,
uh,
who had done it,
did he know anything about,
uh,
who had done it?
He blurted out her name,
Mario and demand says this really wasn't an accusation.
In fact,
this,
this was just,
this was just a meaningless word,
uh,
blurted out that he is,
that there is no possibility really of confession that there is real,
there is no real subjectivity that can affirm or deny guilt or responsibility.
In other words,
a lot of things that needless to say,
attracted the attention of a public that wasn't perhaps so much concerned that
he had written these articles,
but that he had never for the rest of his career admitted having done so.
And other words that he had suppressed a past.
Nobody really believed he still had these sympathies.
But the whole question was,
why didn't he fess up?
Why didn't he come clean?
And of course they took the prolonged written ribbon to be his sort of
allegorical way of suggesting that he couldn't possibly confessed because nobody
can confess.
There's no human subjectivity,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So as I say,
there was a considerable controversy,
controversy swirling around this article.
Uh,
and um,
it has been very difficult for just as just as is the case with high degree.
It has been very difficult,
uh,
to read demand in the same way again,
as a result of what we now know.
Let me just,
let me just say though,
um,
also that,
and I think this was largely confessed by the people engaged in the controversy,
although some people did go farther.
There is no cryptically and coded right ism either in demand or in
deconstruction.
There are two possible ways of reacting to what deconstruction calls
undecidability.
That is to say the impossibilities of are really being able to form a grounded
opinion about anything.
There are two possible ways of reacting to this.
One positive and one negative.
The negative way is to say that undecidability opens a void in the intellect and
in consciousness into which fanaticism and tyranny can rush.
In other words,
if there is a sort of considered,
um,
and skillfully argued resistance to opinion,
call that deconstruction.
Then in the absence of decently grounded,
decently argued opinion,
you get this void into which fanaticism and tyranny can rush.
That's the negative response to undecidability.
And it's of course something that,
uh,
that a,
a view that many of us may entertain.
The positive voice reaction,
however,
to undecidability is this undecidability is a perpetually vigilant scrutiny of
all opinion as such precisely in order to withstand and to resist those most
egregious and incorrigible opinions of all the opinions of fanaticism and
tyranny and other Ed.
You can take two views in effect of skepticism,
the one that it is in its insistence on a lack of foundation for,
for,
for opinion,
uh,
a kind of of,
of passive acquiescence in whatever rises up in its face.
And on the other hand,
you can argue that without skepticism,
everybody is vulnerable to excessive commitment to opinion,
which is precisely the thing that skepticism is supposed to resist.
Now,
uh,
this isn't the first time in this course that I've paused over,
a moment at a crossroads where you can't possibly take both paths,
but where it is obviously very,
very different,
difficult to make up one's mind and it may indeed be a matter more than one can
say or care to admit.
It may ultimately be a matter of temperament,
which path one chooses to take.
All right?
Now,
in any case,
uh,
while we're on the subject of deconstruction in general,
and before we get into demand,
let me adjust a,
that there is one other way,
if I may not to criticize deconstruction.
It's always supposed popularly that deconstruction denies the existence of any
reality outside a text.
Derrida famously notoriously said there is nothing outside of the text.
All right?
What he meant by that of course,
is that there is nothing but text that is to say I the entire tissue and
structure and nature of our lives,
including history,
which we know textually,
okay,
is all there is.
Our lives are textual lives.
That's what he meant.
He didn't mean to say the text is here and the text contains everything that
matters and nothing else exists anyway.
Okay.
When he meant to say is that there is nothing but text in the sense that
absolutely everything we ordinarily take to be just our kind of spontaneously
lived existence is in fact mediated in the ways we've already discussed at
length in this course.
And we'll discuss more by our knowledge and that our knowledge is textual.
All right?
That's,
that's what he meant.
But as I say,
it's widely misunderstood and Demonn,
uh,
in the,
um,
in,
in the fourth passage on your sheet,
um,
returns to the attack against this popular supposition and says
in genuine semiology as well as in other linguistically oriented theories,
the referential funk and notice the citation of Yacob sin here the referential
function of language is not being denied far from it.
In other words,
this stuff out there,
you know,
we're,
we're with,
it's not a question of,
of the idealist who was refuted by Dr. Johnson who kicked a stone and leaked
away in terrible pain saying,
I refuted.
Thus nobody denies the existence of the stone.
All right?
It's not that that is not at all the the case.
You know,
reality is their reality is what it is and the referential function is
perpetually in play in language trying to hook on to that reality.
The referential function of language is not being denied far from it.
What is in question is its authority for natural or phenomenal cognition.
That is to say,
can we know what things are not that things are,
but what things are using the instrument of language.
The mine goes on to say very challengingly what we call ideology is precisely
the confusion of linguistic with natural reality of reference with phenomenal
realism.
In other words,
idealized ideology is nothing other than the belief that language my language,
what I say and what I think in language speaks true.
That is,
that's the position taken up.
Not at all the same thing as the saying as as saying what's out there doesn't
exist.
Nothing to do with that.
All right now demands early career was influenced primary and I'm not speaking
of the very early career in which he wrote these articles,
but the early career,
uh,
involving the essays which were collected,
collected in his first book,
blindness and insight,
his early career as mainly influenced by French intellectual Islam in
particular,
John John Paul sock was being in time,
uh,
being and nothingness,
sorry.
And uh,
and the arguments of blindness and insight is largely a to be understood,
not so much in terms of demands later preoccupations with linguistics,
as with the negotiation of Psychiatry and existentialism,
uh,
into a kind of literary theory,
and the texts,
particularly the texts called criticism and crisis.
The first one that I quote on your sheet can best be read in those terms,
but soon enough,
um,
demand did,
uh,
accept and embrace the influence of so sir in linguistics and structuralism and
his vocabulary,
hence,
hence forth,
took these forms.
The vocabulary that we have to wrestle with for today's essay is taken in part
from Yaka person's understanding of the relationship between metaphor and
metonymy.
And we will have,
we will have more to say about that.
Um,
but in the meantime,
uh,
it's probably on this occasion once we accept them both as having come under the
influence of the same form of linguistic thinking,
uh,
to say a little bit about the similarities and differences that exist between
Derrida and demand.
Now similarly,
they both take for granted that it is very difficult to think about beginnings,
but at the same time one has to have some way,
some Prodo structuralist way of understanding that before a certain moment.
That is to say before us a certain synchronic cross section.
Uh,
things were different from the way they were in some successive moment.
And so in the second passage on your sheet to which I'll return,
in the end,
we find demand saying literary theory can be said to come into being when that
is demands version of the event.
Literary theory can be said to come into being when,
and he agrees with Derrida and saying,
well,
sure,
you know,
God came into being,
man came into being,
consciousness came into being.
That's all very well,
but they're just head signifiers in metaphysics.
There's something different about language.
All right?
And what both Derrida and demand say about the difference when one thinks of
language coming into being,
from thinking about all those other things coming into being,
as the language does not purport to stand outside of itself.
They cannot stand outside of itself.
It cannot constitute itself.
It is perpetually caught up in it's own systematic nature so that it's a center.
Uh,
and we have to resist,
uh,
excessive commitment to this idea of it being a center.
But it is at least not a center which somehow stands outside of itself.
And is a setter only in the sense that it has some remote,
hidden,
impersonal,
distant.
Because language is caught up in itself in a way that all of these other moments
were not.
So.
And then also I think that you can see the similarity there to Derrida and
demands way insisting,
insisting on these binary relations,
uh,
as interdependent and mutual comparable to the sort of thing that I've been
talking about.
In Derrida,
take eight 91 92,
for example,
bottom of very bottom of h 98,
91 over to eight 92,
man says it is easy enough to see that the apparent glorification of the critic,
philosopher and the name of truth is in fact a glorification of the poet as the
primary source of this truth.
Now,
he does not mean,
uh,
as Freud for example,
met men in saying,
ah,
the poet's came before me in the poets knew everything I knew before I knew it.
He does not mean that at all what he means,
what he says in the following clauses.
If truth is the recognition of the systematic character of a certain kind of
error,
then it would be fully dependent on the prior existence of this error.
In other words,
truth arises out of error.
Error is not a deviance from truth.
Alright?
Error is not a poetic elaboration on things which somehow,
uh,
as it does in Plato's view undermines the integrity of that truth identified by
philosophers.
On the contrary philosophy properly understood is what comes into being when one
has achieved full recognition of a preexisting error.
And that is,
uh,
the way in which demonn wants to think about the relationship between precisely
between literature and other forms of speech.
And in saying that,
I want to move immediately to the differences with Derrida.
Derrida,
as I said,
beliefs in a kind of seamless web of discourse or discursivity we are awash in
discourse.
Yes,
we can provisionally or heuristically speak of one form of discourse as opposed
to another literature,
law,
theology,
science and so on.
But it is all easily undermined and demystified as something that has real
independent integrity.
Demand does not believe this.
Demand thinks on the contrary,
that there is such a thing as literariness.
He follows [inaudible] much more consistently in this regard.
Then Derrida does and he says again and again,
he says that the,
um,
that,
uh,
the important thing is to insist on the difference between literature and other
forms of discourse.
He says also,
uh,
and,
and there are all kinds of passages I could,
I could elicit in support of this.
Let me just quickly read a few.
Page 83,
page eight,
83,
uh,
about two thirds of the way down the left hand column,
he says,
uh,
where he's talking about the [inaudible] sounding very much like a Russian
formalists talking about the,
the what literature in particular has exclusively that other forms of discourse
don't have.
He says,
literature cannot merely be conceived,
be received as a definite unit of referential,
meaning that can be decoded without leaving a residue.
The code is unusually conspicuous,
complex and attic matic.
It attracts an inordinate amount of attention to itself and this has to acquire
the rigor of a method.
The structural moment of concentration on the code for its own sake cannot be
avoided.
And literature necessarily breeds its own formalism.
And the interest of time.
I'm going to skip over a few other passages that I was going to read to you.
In reinforcement of this insistent on insistence on demands part that literature
differs from other forms of discourse.
The remaining question being literature differs from other forms of discourse.
How well is that disclosure of error that other forms of discourse supposing
themselves to refer to things remain on aware of literature knows itself to be
fictive.
Ultimately we reached the conclusion that if we're to think of literature where
to think of something that is made up,
not something that is based on something but something that is made up in the
first passage.
The statement about language by criticism that sign and meaning can never
coincide is what is precisely taken for granted.
In the kind of language we call literary literature.
Unlike everyday language begins on the far side of this knowledge,
it is the only form of knowledge free from the fallacy of unmediated expression.
In other words,
free from the fallacy that when I say it is raining,
I mean I'm a meteorologist and I mean it is raining literature.
When it says it is raining,
is not looking out the window.
I mean you know this is,
this is after all perfectly true it.
The author of,
I have been looking out of the window,
but literature as we and counter it as a text is not looking out the window.
How can a techs look out of the window when literature says it is raining,
it's got something else as one might say.
In view,
all of us demand continues.
No this although we know it and the misleading way of a wishful assertion of the
opposite.
Yet the truth emerges in the fore knowledge we possess of the true nature of
literature when we refer to it as fiction,
and this is why in the last passage on your sheet from the interview with Stefan
orso demand is willing to venture on a categorical distinction between his own
work and that of his very close friend Jacques Derrida.
He says,
I have attended a tendency to put upon texts and inherent and he means literary
texts.
I have a tendency to put upon texts and inherent authority,
which is stronger,
I think,
than Derrida is willing to put on them in a complicated way.
I would hope to the statement that the text deconstructs itself,
in other words,
literature is the perpetual denial of its referentiality.
The text deconstructs itself is self deconstructive rather than being
deconstructed by a philosophical intervention that which Jacques Derrida.
Dot.
Does.
That is to say Jacques Derrida bringing his,
uh,
his sort of delicate sledge hammer down on every conceivable form of utterance
from the outside,
right.
Rather than being deconstructed by a philosophical intervention from outside the
text.
So those,
some remarks then on the differences and the similarities between,
uh,
between,
demand and Derrida.
Now,
semiology in rhetoric historically comes near the end of the period that
structure sign and play inaugurate.
It's,
that is to say it is published,
uh,
in allegories of reading.
It is a text,
uh,
which we can,
which,
which we can date from the early 1980s.
Well,
it was published originally as an article 17,
1979.
Um,
but this is also near the end of a period of flourishing that dairy does.
Essay.
Uh,
inaugurate a and other things have begun,
uh,
to become crucial even before the death of demand.
And the revelations about his past,
there were a lot of people sort of shaking their fists and saying,
what about history?
What about reality?
You know,
I've already suggested that in a variety of ways.
This is a response that can be naive,
but it is still very much in the air.
Um,
and demand says,
uh,
in this atmosphere of response at the top of page 83,
the left hand column,
he says,
we speak as if with the problems of literary form resolved once and forever,
and with techniques of structural analysis refined to near perfection,
we could now move beyond formalism toward the questions that really interest us
and reap at last,
the fruits of the aesthetic concentration on techniques that prepared us for
this decisive step.
Obviously,
I think by this time you can realize what he's saying is if we make this move,
if we move beyond formalism,
we have forgotten the cardinal rule of the Russian formalists,
namely,
that there is no distinction between form and content.
In other words,
that we in effect cat move beyond formalism and that it is simply a procedurally
mistaken notion that we can,
and that's,
uh,
the position of course pursued in,
in this essay,
the task of the asset is to deny the complimentarity,
the mutual reinforcement even and rigorous rhetorical analysis like that of
Gerage Janette told her off backed and others,
all of whom he says have regressed from the rigor of Yacob sin to deny that in
rhetorical analysis,
rhetorical and grammatical aspects of discourse can be considered collusive or
continuous or cooperative with each other.
Now,
I've already suggested the problems are which that our eyes when you consider
this term,
even in and of itself,
I'm actually a ripping off by the way.
An Essay,
uh,
about,
of Jacques Derrida was called,
uh,
called,
called.
Oh.
Anyway,
it's that essay and,
and,
and now you'll never know my source.
Uh,
and in any case,
uh,
the dairy dot two in,
in this essay,
uh,
which is called,
is at,
is at pains to argue that you can't reduce grammar to rhetoric or rhetoric to
grammar.
Um,
and so as we think about these things,
as I suggest,
we've already introduced what Demonn,
uh,
drives home to us.
He says,
boy,
this is complicated theory.
Uh,
I'm in over my head,
so I better just get practical and give you some examples of what I mean.
And so he takes up,
uh,
all,
all in the family,
Archie and Edith,
what was the name of that show all in the family?
Uh,
Andrew talks about the moment in which Archie becomes exasperated,
uh,
when Edith begins to tell him that the difference,
the difference between a bowling shoes laced over and bowling shoes laced under
this end.
Response to Archie's question,
what's the difference?
In other words,
Archie has asked a rhetorical question.
I don't care what the differences is.
The meaning of the rhetorical question.
Itas a reader of sublime simplicity as demand says,
Edith misinterprets the rhetorical question as a grammatical question.
What is the difference?
I'm curious to know,
and then proceeds to explain that there's lacing over on the one hand and lacing
under.
On the other hand,
Archie of course,
can't stand this because for him it's perfectly clear that a rhetorical question
as a rhetorical question demands point is a question is both rhetorical and
grammatical and the one cannot be reduced to the other.
Both readings are available.
He complicates without changing the argument.
By then referring to yeats's poem among school children,
which culminates,
you remember,
it has a whole series of metaphors,
uh,
of attempting seeming at least to attempt the synthesis of,
of,
of opposites concluding.
How can we tell the dancer from the dance?
Another question right now,
the rhetorical question completes the usual reading of the poem.
The answer to the rhetorical question is we can't tell the difference between
the dancer and the dance.
They are unified in a synthetic symbolizing symbolic moment that constitutes the
work of art.
And so,
and all the preceding Matt metaphors lead up to this triumphant sense of unity,
of symbolic unity as the essence of the work of art.
A unity,
which by the way entails among other things,
the unity of author and text,
right?
The unity of agent and production,
the unit of all of those things,
which,
uh,
as we've seen much literary theory is interested in collapsing.
How can we tell the dancer from the dance?
Well,
the man says,
wait a minute though.
This is also a grammatical question.
And if you stop and think of it as a grammatical question,
you say to yourself,
Gee,
that's a very good question,
isn't it?
Because of course,
you know,
the easiest thing in the world is to tell the dancer from the dance,
I am the dancer and this is the dance I'm doing.
And,
and,
and obviously they're not the same thing,
right?
I mean,
what nonsense poetry speaks,
you know what I mean?
It's particularly ridiculous.
You know there are,
there is also a grammatical sense which won't go away just because your rigorous
sort of symbolic interpretation insists that it should go away.
All right.
And then demand who happens to be a gate scholar,
his,
his eight,
he published a dissertation on Yates and really knows his Yates starts at
deucing examples from all over the canon of Yates to the effect that to the
effect that um,
Yates is perfectly knowing and self conscious about these grammatical
differences.
That there is a measure of irony in the poem that saves it from this sort of
symbolizing mystification and he makes a perfectly plausible argument to the
effect that the question is grammatical rather than rhetorical.
He's not claiming and he,
and he points this out to us,
he's not claiming that his explication is the true one.
It's not as point at all.
He's glamming only that it is available and can be adduced from what we call
evidence in the same way that the symbolic interpretation based on the
rhetorical question is available and can be adduced from evidence and that these
two viewpoints are irreducible.
They cannot be reconciled as traditional.
So the relationship between rhetoric and grammar in studying,
uh,
the rhetorical and grammatical effects of literature take for granted.
That's his argument.
He's,
it's a kind of infighting because he's talking to people who are actually very
close allies.
He's saying they're doing great work,
but they forget this one little thing.
You cannot reconcile rhetoric and grammar.
Every sentence has a predication.
And if every sentence has a predication,
it also has the structure of a metaphor and the metaphor in a sentence and the
predication in a sentence are always going to be at odds.
A metaphor is what we call a poetic lie.
Everybody knows a is not B.
A predication on the other hand usually goes forward in the service of
referentiality.
It's a truth claim of some kind,
right?
But if rhetoric and grammatic Galtee coexist in any sentence,
the sentence is truth claim and it's lie are perpetually at odds with each
other.
And just taking the sentence as a sentence,
irrespective of any kind of inference we might make about intentions.
I mean,
we know perfectly well what Edith in tens and what Archie bunker and tens,
it's not as if we're confused about the meaning of what they're saying.
It's just that other meanings are available.
And since they're not on the same page,
those two other meanings co-exist painfully and irreducibly at odds.
Right?
But there are cases,
suppose Archie bunker where RK debunker suppose Archie bunker where Jacques
Derrida and Jacques Derrida came along and said,
let's,
is it different halls?
Right.
That would be,
that would be an entirely different matter.
Wouldn't cause you would have absolutely no idea whether the question was
rhetorical or grammatical right there.
It wouldn't be there.
It wouldn't be possible to invoke an intention because the whole complication of
Derrida is precisely to the raise the question about not knowing,
not being able to voice the difference between difference in Dfl Hos and uh,
and,
and not knowing whether Archie is right or whether Edith is right Proust.
I don't have time for it,
but I will,
but it's,
but it's a marvelous reading of,
of a,
of,
of the,
that wonderful passage,
uh,
in which,
um,
remember that he's set it up at the beginning of the essay,
whether with a kind of wonderful cunning,
that,
a sense of structure by talking about the grandmother and Proust who's always
driving Marcel out into the garden because she can't stand the interiority of
his reading.
Well,
then later on in the essay demand quotes this wonderful passage in which mock
sell talks about the way in which he brought the inside what brought the outside
inside as he was perpetually conscious of everything that was going on out there
during the process of his reading.
So that ultimately in the charmed moment of his rating,
there was no difference between inside and outside.
In other words,
a metaphor,
uh,
a rhetorical understanding of the relationship between inside and outside has
been accomplished.
But then grammatical analysis shows that the whole structure of the passage is
additive.
That is,
is,
is put,
is adding things on,
is complicating and reinforcing an argument without insisting on the,
on,
on identity,
on the underlying,
uh,
identity on which metaphor depends.
And so he calls this met anemic.
By the way,
I'm going to leave also to your access to your sections,
the strange confusion that ensues on taking,
uh,
in taking a rhetorical device Mytonomy and making it synonymous with grammar on
the access of combination.
I leave that to your sections,
but in the meantime,
he says,
no,
no.
Then I guess this passage isn't rhetorical after all,
it must be mad an Ivig,
but wait,
it is spoken by a voice there.
This wonderful overarching voice that unifies everything.
After all,
this is what I call says,
demand the rhetoric's ization of grammar.
Right?
But wait,
but wait,
that voice is not the author.
That voice is a speaker.
That voices box cell,
uh,
you know,
performing his wonderful,
uh,
sort of metaphoric magic.
Uh,
but we know that the author is painstakingly putting this together in the most
low,
boring,
laborious,
kind of composed way,
uh,
making something up in a,
in an additive way.
That's not rhetorical.
It all,
its grammatical.
This is a supreme writer putting together long sentences.
And so,
wait a minute.
It must be after all the grammatic cessation of rhetoric,
the whole point of which is that the worm of interpretation keeps turning right.
It doesn't arbitrarily stop anywhere because rhetoric and grammar remain
irreducible.
We have to keep thinking of them as being uncooperative with each other.
Okay,
I have to stop.
There might add a word or two,
but on Thursday we turn,
I'm afraid with a certain awkwardness.
I wish there were an interview Vini weekend to Freud and Peter Brooks,
but in the meantime,
we'll see you then.